hey there welcome to con O'Brien needs a
friend I just announced the show
speaking through sona's you were
grumbling or coughing or what were you
doing clearing your throat I was
clearing I'm a throat clearer I clear my
I'm I do that I made it quite clear I
was starting the show and I heard I can
I say something though you sounded like
you were going to start it like four
times but you didn't so I just thought
you weren't you never know when I will
strike that's the oh my God what is
wrong with my God that was real this is
a mess uh that was Matt gorley sneezing
his mind
out uh do you got the um you okay you
got the sniffles just I have so much Co
right
now let's go we're in this chamber
together we're broadcasting from the
sphere in Las Vegas yeah maybe it is
time that we take stock of of you know
I'm the editor and I know what we all do
our own little ticks because you clear
your throat quite a
bit and you do what you just did right
now which is to begin a sentence with a
yeah you do that I hear that listen I do
that on purpose I go and that's my way
of letting the sound engineer know that
I'm about to speak it's a little code
that we worked out isn't that right Ed
and guess what another thing I think
that it's shows a lot of uh forethought
and planning on my part do you know how
how much work that is I take all of
those out why I put those in on purpose
wait Matt has a tick too he he does a
lot of plosives Pop explosives yeah you
do you do a lot ofes and then Eduardo
has to take those out that's probably a
lie and wardo also you just stink to
high heaven oh yeah yeah yeah you just I
mean I don't know what it is that comes
through on the mics I know yeah we were
talking about our mic tick you have an A
you got personal that's just not cool
okay yeah let's try it all at once uh I
will we'll all do our personal things
that we do all at once and AO you yeah
put your armpit to the
microphone and 1 2 3 go
you before I begin I go is that right
and you have to take it out well and
then you'll you go like all right what
if I tried not to do that anymore that
would make your life easier oh boy would
it yeah maybe I substitute it for
something else so anyway I but see the
audience wouldn't even know that this is
an issue because they're never in the
final product same with the throat
clearing I'm going oh really I try to
clear it off mik you do not you
I do I sometimes do I do this and then I
cough at my uh elbow that's nice yeah
what do you do gargle with fava beans
before you get on the mic no I don't
know why I do that I think I talk
incorrectly speak incorrectly speak in
shut up I'm sorry that was mean um that
was mean think you're okay with that one
yeah it was so just instinctive no I
think I speak incorrectly you're
supposed to speak from your diaphragm
I'm just like up here well I think oh
God God well these ones I don't have to
take out which no you can leave these in
yeah I'm G to keep an eye on that from
now on because you work very hard uh
making sure that this product and it is
a product goes out to people for free
for some reason uh is of the highest
quality and you work hard removing our
little ticks God knows what the listener
or fan isn't hearing maybe for this the
verer Herzog episode which I have not
yet edited I'll leave them all in and
just just for a taste just so people can
see I wouldn't do it I think people will
hate the podcast and we might be sued by
verer Herzog oh it's possible he he's
got some of his own
ticks he accused me of being quite
insane several
times he accuses everyone of being
you're enveloped in Madness I saw him
yelling at a toad outside the
studio to Mr Toad you are enveloped by
sanity and Madness Mr Herz would you
like to come in oh sorry how are you Mr
tote
Ribbit uh I am going to do the best I
can to be a little more professional do
we have buttons that we can push like
delay buttons or like cough buttons
buttons not yeah not why don't we have
those because I recently recorded
something at sxm Studios sirusxm and
they had all these cool buttons that
were quite helpful and I thought huh
these don't exist in the studio that
Eduardo designed I was told not to give
you toys that you can like just push
atar my God that makes so much sense
whoever made that call made the right
call I'm like a chimp in a in a capsule
I'm like a chimp in a Space Capsule
don't let the chimp actually don't let
him near any
controls I love that there was a
conversation about it adult adults had a
conversation and said there shouldn't be
any button
that is great R anybody who was it I
want to know give me a name I can't say
I bet it was Jeff Ross no was it Jeff
Ross oh Adam Sachs can neither confirm
nor deny no you can't make him do it the
snitches snitches get stitches you can't
make him do that not around here they
don't snitches get passive aggressive
snitches get riches here yeah exactly
I'll tell you who it was it was Adam I
don't know I don't know about that I
don't I don't think it would be a
problem to have those buttons and it's
not like you can go crazy with a cough
button now if there was a button that
made a coughing sound I'd be hitting
that all the time or the fart button oh
my God I would love a fart Buton just
hitting that I'd be and you know what
I'd make sure that I was waiting till
like and today we're talking to Dame
Judy Dench Dame Judy d you've done such
an incredible well thank you why I just
and
I I'm hitting all these sound effects
buttons and then she just says I am
never doing that podcast again dve Judy
jch that got 8 million
listeners and your movie went through
the roof then have me back instantly I
love that farting
podcast I want buttons get me Buttons at
you buttons the king demands A F button
I want buttons I want levers I want all
kinds of things I want to look like Wily
Wonka you know what we should get him is
a bit do you remember bit yeah it's that
toy that has all those things it's
basically like a kids toy but you have
to like hit it and it
goes
D oh my God what a great podcast we
would have if I had that thing yeah
that' be fantastic wait you looked
uncertain all right well uh there's no
transition here I also need a transition
that that would help right now yeah well
my guest
today